>>> NEW N REPORTING, A NOTABLE
SHIFT OF TOP DEMOCRATS FEEL
ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN RUNNING IN
2024 WITH THE MIDTERMS FAST
APPROACHING.
MANY PARTY LEADERSES AND OTHERS
WEIGH WHETHER THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD RUN FOR A SECOND TERM.
ISAAC, INTERESTING REPORTING.
WE HEARD THE SENATOR SPEAKING TO
US SAYING HE THINKS BIDEN SHOULD
RUN.
IT TOOK PUSHING AND PRODDING BUT
HE SAID IT.
YOU ARE RUNNING INTO THE SAME
DISCUSSIONS.
>> YEAH.
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO SENATOR TESTER.
EVENTUALLY SAYING, YES, I HOPE
HE RUNS BUT WITH THIS FEELING
I'M NOT SURE.
PEOPLE ARE NOT CONVINCED AND
FEEL MUCH BETTER ABOUT THE IDEA
OF HIM RUNNING.
BIDEN'S NUMBERS ARE IMPROVING.
SUCCESSES TO POINT TO.
DEMOCRATS IN A BETTER MOOD THESE
DAYS.
>> GAS PRICES.
>> OBVIOUSLY.
IS THIS GOING TO LEAD TO JOE
BIDEN WHO WILL TURN 80 THIS
NOVEMBER.
WOULD TURN 82 SHORTLY AFTER THE
2024 ELECTION.
IT DOES COME BACK TO AGE.
PEOPLE AREN'T QUITE SURE HE IS
GOING TO DO IT.
>> BUT IF YOU WERE TO CONTRAST
WHAT DEMOCRATIC OFFICIALS SAY
NOW VERSUS SIX MONTHS AGO?
>> IT IS NIGHT AND DAY.
IN THE REPORTING THERE'S A STORY
THAT THE PARTY LEADERS HAD MIT
IN MARCH AND SAID HOW DO WE GET
JOE BIDEN NOT TO RUN?
THEY HAD ANOTHER ONE TWO WEEKS
AGO OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON
TALKING ABOUT MAYBE HE SHOULD
RUN AND THEN COUCHED IN THIS AS
A MEMBER SAID IF HE WANTS TO RUN
PEOPLE WILL SUPPORT HIM AND THE
COMMENTS LAST WEEK THAT MADE
PEOPLE THINK THAT HE WAS REALLY
UNDECIDED ABOUT IT HAVE REALLY
SHAKEN THROUGH A LOT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ESTABLISHMENT.
>> STAY TUNED ON THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JOINING US IS CNN SENIOR
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT PAT
AVALON AND MARGARET HOOVER.
WE WERE TALKING TO SENATOR
TESTER ABOUT THIS.
IT TOOK A LITTLE PUSHING AND
PRODDING BUT HE HOPES THAT JOE
BIDEN WILL RUN AND IT DOES SOUND
AS THOUGH THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE HAVING NOW AROUND
THE DINNER TABLE ARE DIFFERENT
THAN SIX MONTHS AGO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> GO AHEAD.
>> LOOK.
I THINK HE HAD A LOT OF
OBJECTIVE WINS.
GAS PRICES ARE LOWER.
PEOPLE FEEL BULLISH ABOUT THE
MIDTERMS.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT BIDEN ALWAYS
RAN AS A CANDIDATE OF -- SOMEONE
WHO WOULD GET TRUMP OUT OF
OFFICE AND BE A BRIDGE TO A NEW
GENERATION AND IMPLICIT IS HE
MIGHT BE A ONE TERMER.
THE QUESTION IS WHO'S BETTER
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP?
>> I'LL JUST QUICKLY ADD TO A
CERTAIN DEGREE IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT EVERY DEMOCRAT IS SAYING
BUT WHETHER JOE BIDEN THINKS HE
IS GOING TO RUN AND DECIDES TO
RUN.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT TAKING A CENSUS
OF THE DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS OR
THE SENATE.
SO I UNDERSTAND ANECDOTALLY FROM
DEMOCRATS I TALK TO THAT HAVE A
SENSE OF THE WHITE HOUSE THAT HE
IS MOVING FORWARD AND DOESN'T
INTEND TO STEP ASIDE.
>> YEAH.
AS WE BOTH KNOW COVERING THIS IN
2015 AND 2016.
THIS IS AN INTENSELY PERSONAL
DECISION FOR JOE BIDEN.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016
WHEN HIS SON BEAU PASSED AWAY.
SO HE MAY MAKE A SIMILAR
CALCULATION.
MUCH MORE EMOTIONAL ONE I
SUPPOSE.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEW BOOK
ABOUT TRUMP.
MAGGIE HABERMAN SAID HE
DESCRIBED FLORIDA GOVERNOR
DESANTIS AS FAT, PHONY AND WHINY
AND CLAIMING CREDIT FOR HELPING
DESANTIS TO BE GOVERNOR.
THERE'S A SIMMERING ATTITUDE
BETWEEN THEM.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THIS AND HOW DO
YOU SEE THIS PLAYING OUT?
>> I HAVE BEEN WONDERING FOR
SOMETIME.
ANY REPUBLICAN GOING TOE TO TOE
WITH DONALD TRUMP GETS A
NICKNAME, BRANDED UNFAVORABLY BY
DONALD TRUMP AND WE DID NOT KNOW
WHAT DONALD TRUMP'S NICKNAME
INSULT WOULD BE FOR RON DESANTIS
AND WE HAVE A MUCH CLEARER SENSE
OF HOW DONALD TRUMP WOULD GO
AFTER DESANTIS.
TIRED JEB.
>> LYING TED.
>> HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET OUT
FROM UNDER THE CHARACTERIZATION
THAT DONALD TRUMP GIVES THEM.
I HAVE LOCK BELIEVED IT IS A
MATTER OF TIME AND TRUMP WILL
HOLD THE FIRE TO DO THE SAME
THING TO RON DESANTIS AS EVERY
OTHER REPUBLICAN TO TEST HIS
MEDDLE AGAINST HIM.
IT STRIKES ME THAT REPUBLICANS
HAVE NOT LEARNED THE LESSON OF
HOW DONALD TRUMP TREATS PEOPLE
WHO DARE TO GO UP AGAINST HIM.
>> WHEN WILL REPUBLICANS
TIPTOEING AROUND THE SCHOOL YARD
BULLY AND REALIZE THAT STRAW MEN
ARE ALWAYS WEAK?
THE DEGREE THAT SERVE AFRAID TO
TAKE ON TRUMP DIRECTLY, MAYBE
DESANTIS HAS THE LIKABILITY OF
PEOPLE TO RUN SUCCESSFULLY FOR
THE PRESIDENT BUT THE
REPUBLICANS NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THEY WILL HAVE TO TAKE THE BULLY
ON DIRECTLY.
THAT'S HOW YOU DEFEAT THE SCHOOL
YARD BULLY.
UNTIL THEY GET SOME SPINE AND
STONES AND REALIZE THAT PROOF WE
ARE STUCK IN THIS INSULT SAND
BOX POLITICS LAND.
>> THE ONLY ONE WHO HAS IS LIZ
CHENEY.
>> SURE.
>> IN A 30% BASE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THAT BASE IS DONALD TRUMP'S.
>> SHE SAID AT THE TEXAS TRIBUNE
FESTIVAL OVER THE WEEKEND WILL
NOT BE A REPUBLICAN IF DONALD
TRUMP IS THE NOMINEE FOR THE
PARTY IN 2024.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I REALLY UNDERSTAND THOSE
COMMENTS ON A DEEP VISCERAL
LEVEL.
PEOPLE LIKE ME HANG THE HATS ON
THE REPUBLICANS THAT VOTED FOR
CONVICTION OF WHICH THERE ARE
VERY FEW.
WE NEED PRIMARY ELECTION REFORM
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE MORE DIVERSITY IN
THE PARTY WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
QUESTION OF DONALD TRUMP AND
ISSUES AND SO IT IS HARD TO
IMAGINE.
WE KNOW THAT THE PARTY REALLY IS
THE -- THE BASE IS CAPTURED BY
DONALD TRUMP BUT IF HE IS THE
NOMINEE IT IS DIFFICULT TO SELF
IDENTIFY AS A REPUBLICAN.
>> LOOK.
IF REPUBLICANS TRADITIONALLY
HAVE BEEN BASED AROUND
PATRIOTISM AND ELECT SOMEONE
THAT TRIED TO OVERTURN AN
ELECTION, I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S A REASON MORE AMERICANS
IDENTIFY AS INSPECTEDS.
BUT THIS IS REALLY A GUT CHECK
FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND
PLAYING THIS GAME THAT MITCH
McCONNELL KNOWS THE TRUTH AND IN
PUBLIC SAYING WE'LL SUPPORT HIM.
THAT IS PARTY OVER COUNTRY AND
UNSUSTAINABLE FOR A DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC.
>> ANOTHER PERSON WHO WANTS TO
BE PRESIDENT IS SENATOR TED
CRUZ.
HE GOT INTO AN EXCHANGE WITH
AUDIENCE MEMBERS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
>> THE SINGLE BEST STEP TO STOP
THEM IS HAVE ARMED OFFICERS ON
CAMPUS THAT CAN STOP THEM BEFORE
THEY KILL OUR KIDS.
LOOK.
INSTEAD YOU GUYS CAN SING WITH
THEM AND HOPE THEY WILL JUST
STOP BUT WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
DOESN'T WORK.
[ INAUDIBLE ]
>> AT THE END THERE SOMEONE
SHOUTED 18-YEAR-OLDS DO NOT NEED
AN AR-15.
AN EMOTIONAL MOMENT THERE.
>> YEAH.
NO.
I WATCHED THE WHOLE THING SO
THAT YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO.
I HALFWAY THROUGH STOPPED AND
THOUGHT TED CRUZ, THE 1990s ARE
CALLING YOU FOR THE NRA TALKING
POINTS BACK.
IT DOESN'T LOOK AT THE REALITY
IN TEXAS.
LOOK AT THE OTHER SENATOR FROM
TEXAS.
JOHN CORNYN.
TOOK TO HEART SERIOUSLY WHAT
HAPPENED IN UVALDE.
THEY PASSED THE FIRST BIPARTISAN
GUN LEGISLATION SINCE 1994.
SINCE 1990s.
OKAY?
THEY GOT TOO LITTLE CREDIT FOR
IT.
CORNYN IS NOT IN BAD SHAPE IN
TEXAS.
TED CRUZ IS WAY OUT OF STEP WITH
YOU HAVE REPUBLICAN OPERATIVES
THAT RECOGNIZE REASONABLE
CONTROLS IS NOT AN INFRINGEMENT
ON RIGHTS.
>> THERE'S SO MUCH EMOTION ON
THE ISSUE AND DEALING WITH
PEOPLE IMPACTED BY A SCHOOL
SHOOTING IN A COMMUNITY YOUR
HEART HAS TO GO OUT TO THEM.
END OF STORY.
TO GET IN A SHOUTING MATCH WITH
SOMEONE HURTS OVER T